thirty eight thousand jobs that's the
number created in the month of May it
was more than a hundred and twenty
thousand below the median estimate in
our survey of economists and the lowest
job growth in this country since
September of 2010 not all of what we saw
in the month of May was due to the
verizon strike yes information and
telecom employment was down by 34,000
but manufacturing was down by 10,000
mining and logging was down by 11,000 in
construction was down by 15,000 but wait
there's more bad news March payrolls
were revised down 22,000 April payrolls
were revised down 37,000 so we had 38
thousand jobs created in the month of
May but fifty nine thousand jobs
subtracted for the previous two months
and wait there is more 458 thousand
people left the workforce last month so
that had the effect of on the one hand
pushing the unemployment rate down to
four point seven percent the lowest
since November of 2007 but it also
reversed the recent gains in labor force
participation which is now back to
December levels at 62 point six percent
is there anything positive in this Labor
Department jobs report yes wage growth
came in on target up two and a half
percent year-over-year and 0.2% for the
month of May 67,000 jobs were created in
education and health care very strong
employment growth there and long-term
unemployment continued to drop it let me
just recap payrolls non-farm payrolls
growth of just 38,000 that is the least
since September of 2010 the unemployment
rate stands at four point seven percent